[Music]
hallo YouTube just Louis and her friends
this is guns in here
welcome to the 53rd episode of dirty
chest tricks in this episode I am going
to show you one of the amazing counter
trick in the scotch game from the black
perspective the opening arises after the
following model E 4 E Phi Knight to f3
Knight to c6 d4 he captures d4 and
Knight captures d4
if you recall in my past I have covered
a full-time recruiter starting with
Knight to f6 so if you haven't check it
out
I strongly insist you to watch those two
videos which gives you a detail reputa
coverage from the black perspective
however in this video we are going to
look other popular choice namely Bishop
to c5
so black is attacking that night and
white has few choices well amongst them
Bishop to e3 is a mainline but the good
point is no matter however white
responds black response is very much
universal so for example after the move
Bishop to e3 we are going to pressurize
this night one more time with Quinn to
f6
and we reach to one of the most
important Junction in this line here
White has two choices one is c3 and the
second day's night to b5
in this video we are going to look night
to be fire which is a very trappy line
by white however if your opponent
continue with c3 then as I have
highlighted over here black has a very
simple plan to execute namely Knight to
e7 castle and b6 and this is pretty much
you can play against any mortar by wide
and get a very active game
I have attached a model game in the PGN
which will give you a very good
direction how to play such a position
okay let's check out what is happening
after this tricky move night to be fine
so why this immediately I get juicy c7
square and black has to respond very
accurately here my recommendation is you
should start with Bishop captures III so
that is very obvious we want to
checkmate the King on f2 and white
cannot touch on c7 due to the king to be
aid and white will lose a piece so F
captures III is forced well already
black has given white some shutter porn
and on top of everything black has this
lethal check quint which form
if King moves then Queen comes back to
d8 and black has a dream position so
obviously white has to continue with g3
in order to keep the tactical battle
going on
now as per the database the old moon in
this position is Queen back to d8 which
defend the c7 porn however that is not
the case here because we are going to
continue with this aggressive approach
namely Queen captures e4
so black is attacking the rook in the
corner so white responds his force why
it has to capture on c7 and after came
to d8 and Knight captures eight well
it's the case where both the rooks are
gone from the table and the material is
equal but see the difference now as
white knight is trapped in the corner of
the world and this is the important
feature of this line as we are going to
trap down this Knight and remain a
healthy piece up
if you check this position in online
database you will find out that white
has mainly tried four options and let's
see each byte on
the first option I want to consider is
Knight to c3 and one thing you have to
remember is in majority of the cases we
are going to continue with Knight to f6
not Knight G to e7 or White's idea is he
wants to play Queen to d6 so now he can
quickly castle on the Queen side and
also there is some threat on c7 but not
to worry as Black has this villain in
this position namely Quinta 3 so not
only we are stopping by to castle on the
Queen side but right now there is a
threat of Queen captures III something
which white has to pay attention
immediately
well the baseline goes as follows
Queen to c7 check King to e7 and now in
order to protect the e3 pawn white has
to play Queen to f4
one of the game in the database
continued with King to d2 which turns
out is a big-time disaster as after the
simple continuation Knight to d5
attacking to sports Knight captures defy
Queen captures defy King to even and now
very nice move Queen to c5 which once
again renewed the threat and not to
mention that black has a simple plan to
execute namely rook to e8 and King to a
fade and the net result is it is now
only white who has to worry about his
open King so considering these factors
if you put this position in any
professional engine it will tell you
that there is only one defensive
resource here namely Queen to f4 - that
our tasks become more easy as we are
going to exchange the screen and then
continue with this very important move
King to d8 stopping night escape route
well now Whitey's in a big trouble as
majority of the game continued from here
onwards with castle on the Queen side
and surprisingly enough Black has this
winning resource defy which more or less
decide the game on the spot the point is
after the Moon Knight captures d5
we have this intimate zone Bishop to g4
counter attacking the rook and after
Roop goes to anywhere let's say rook to
d2 the simple sequence goes as follows
Knight captures defy rook captures defy
King to see it and you can see that King
is approaching to the night and even
though after rook to g5 Bishop to e6 and
rook captures g7 yes indeed White has
two points for a piece but I don't think
so it's enough and with some accurate
play definitely black is getting his
full point
you
well the second more I want to consider
is Queen to d6 and this is what exactly
most of the white player is hoping for
as I mentioned earlier if you continue
with Knight G to e7 then there is a
nasty trap here guys and you should see
this as after Knight - D - white is
quickly looking to castle on the Queen
side and accordingly many black players
has turned out this move Queen to defy
thinking that okay we can exchange the
Queen and then get the knight in the
corner well guess what here the trap
springs into the picture as after Queen
to c7 chat King to e8 and now this star
moon Queen capture c8 boom white is
completely winning the point is after
night cap to see it and the Moon Knight
to c7 Jack White regain the queen with
interest as it come out with a healthy
Bishop advantage so please remember this
do not play Knight G to e7 rather as I
mentioned earlier always play the move
Knight to f6 and completely avoid this
nasty trap
here White has few options but if he
continued with Knight to c3 or Queen to
c7 then it will transpose to the line
which we already look at it for example
after Quinn to c7 chair King to e7 and
after Knight to c3 and Quint well 3 we
completely transpose to the line which
we have already gone through it
so apart from this the only independent
reply over here is night 2 d2 which
again goes for the same tactic but this
time around it doesn't work
as Black has this very nice
saving resource namely night to eat not
only attacking the Queen but covering
the important see some square and just
to point out how good this position is
for the black I like to show you a email
game between two strong players wear
white continue with Queen to f4 and
black obviously grab the week edge to
pawn okay White Castle on the Queen side
and rightly so
black off for the Queen trade with
Quinto at six if Queen I exchanged then
knight in the corner is a goner so in
the game white find nothing better than
Queen captures epsilon e but that allows
this simple transaction namely Queen
captures III King to be won and now
Queen captures III and suddenly black
emerge with two point advantage and not
to forget this lose night sitting in the
collar
well I just want to point out how easily
black untangle his position after Knight
to e4 black plays Queen to g4 attacking
to sports and after the force reply
Knight to c3 and the move b6 once the
light square bishop become free it is
all doom and gloom for the white camp
you can check out rest of the game in
the PGN where black finish of the white
in mere 29 moves
the card move I want to consider here is
Quinn to g4 and I think this is the only
exception where we are going to continue
with Knight G to e7 so idea is very
simple if I continue with Knight to c3
then Knight to e4 is a very strong
deploy so accordingly white has to
capture on g7 and after that we are
going to continue with rook to g8 if
Queen captures ab7 then Queen captures
s2 and black initiative continues so the
only good reply here for the white is to
capture on at 7 and same time supporting
- to pawn well no matter black has the
equally good move in this position
namely Quint was even attacking only 3
so why response is force when it has to
play Quint with six defending the three
[Music]
but now you see the dark side of playing
with only Queen has black initiative
started with night well file attacking
to sports
after Queen to f6 Knight c37 the e3 pawn
is lost an esper the engine the best
white can do over here is to play the
movie food but even after this it
doesn't stop black to demolish white
camp as after the following sequence
Queen Czech Bishop to e2 Knight to d4
threatening a checkmate or e2 doesn't
matter however white defend
let's say Knight to c3 on the very next
move we can munch the rook in the corner
and easily win this game
you
last but not least what happens after
the MU Queen to d2 you guessed it right
yup of a trademark move Knight to f6 and
after Knight to c3 which has a clear
intention to castle on the Queen side we
are going to continue with rook to e8
the point is after castle on the Queen
side we are targeting the loose III pawn
with Quint we have three
here white has two choices amongst them
Luke - even is a pretty bad one as after
the following sequence Knight to e4
attacking two sports so white responds
his force
white has to capture on e4 and after
Queen takes Bishop to g2 and the move
Queen to e5 you can see the easy route
to the corner night and once white lose
this piece the game is almost gone
one of the very recent game from this
position between 220 200 plus rated
opponent continue with Evo so I do
Bligh's that he cannot wrote a con III
so he choose the tactical path but I'm
afraid it doesn't turn out well as after
Knight captures e4 Knight kept his evil
queen kept a seafood White's idea was he
wants to deliver this check and get his
pawn back but what he missed out is
after f6 Queen captures g7 and the move
Queen to g6 by force white has to
exchange the Queen and later on indeed
managed to lose the night
again you can check the full game in the
PGN where black demolish white very
quickly
that's it guys I hope with this mini
video you are now confident enough to
meet the Moon Knight to be fine
in the squad game remember once you
reach this position play the move Knight
to f6 and no matter however Y triggers
he is going to lose Knight in the corner
and with the careful play you can easily
converted the full point thank you for
watching this video feel free to like
subscribe and comment and I'll meet you
in my next episode very soon bye and
take care